you went and met with this Haram burner
yes it's just so sad because you want to
talk sense into a person like hey okay
look you don't want to be a Muslim no
problem you might not even agree with
what the Quran is saying and the
argument on his end is like I don't care
about your feelings it's facts not
feelings like the fact is that you're
hurting someone's feelings if anyone
could take any type of advice or
guidance non-muslim someone sincere out
there that the prophet my husband was
sent to perfect our manners so the
moment you start doing things that are
out of character out of manners that he
was sent to teach us how to act you're
doing something wrong Muslim are not
Muslim